hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to another episode of my
game engine
series so we've been uh on this journey
of getting the mouse
to be able to click on objects now seen
and actually select things
the previous episode was to do with uh
actually doing some
uh which i'll link up there uh with
doing some kind of read backs from the
frame buffer so that we can actually see
what entity ids
were under the mouse cursor and now
we're going to be extending that so that
we can actually click to finally pick an
object because this is
where everything has been leading to um
and we are basically 90
of the way there we just need to make it
so the click the left mouse button
actually selects the object and we have
to go over object selection as well
because i don't think we have an api for
that so jumping into the code this one
should be a fairly quick episode
hopefully
um we have this pink cube uh and it's
already crashed and i'll tell you why in
a
minute
but um it's because of this tab bar ah
i'd say i can't even
i can't even get not to crash it's okay
we have a fix for this
ah okay so we have an issue clearly
where if we actually look at the call
stack um
[Music]
for whatever reason hover density well
no we know why this happens so hover
density gets set to whatever the pixel
data is if the pixel is
out of bounds if we're trying to access
an area of the frame buffer that is out
of bounds
um because of like the uh x and y
coordinates something being weird
then what that will actually do is
return some garbage data for us
that's an issue because garbage data is
not negative one therefore a blank
entity does not get selected instead an
invalid entity gets selected
and on an invalid entity when we try and
actually retrieve a component of course
and or entity that library is like hey
man i don't know what the entity this is
i'll assert
and that's what you're seeing over there
so luckily this has been fixed by
someone from the community
um shout out to louis philipposi
who has contributed this little pull
request which i think lovely santa has
merged in i just haven't pulled it yet
um so basically you can see in the div
here and you can of course go to the
repository don't forget we're in the
mouse picking branch for now
um you know and read through this change
if you if you care that much but
basically this is just a better way to
actually calculate that viewport min and
max region so that when we actually do
set the rectangle
for like i'm with gizmo and also the
viewport bounds they're actually set
correctly to what they should be
and not some weird values um so that's
an important fix which i'm going to
accept
assuming i have no changes which i don't
so let me just check out that commit and
i'm also going to make sure
that i fetch uh that i'm just to make
sure i'm
i'm on the latest code which i now am so
if we uh
rerun that hopefully what you'll see
here
um is that it doesn't crash and we can
hide the tab bar if we want um
but also what i was going to demonstrate
is without the fix things were basically
a little bit misaligned so we have this
thing up here hover density which
shows the current entity that i'm
hovering over with my mouse
so at the moment and this by the way if
you're if you're new this is not a cube
it's actually three quads with different
different
shades different shades of pink um and
uh so when i hover over them it actually
says what is currently being hovered so
you can see it's pretty much it well it
is pixel perfect
um for top right and left but uh what
used to happen
is if you drop down this tab bar it was
misaligned
right and you can see that's now gone so
if i drop down the tab bar obviously the
size of the viewport has changed and
it's off by this many pixels
but you can see that with this new
contribution um
it's totally fine so thank you again to
louis
and uh yeah
we kind of have this um fix which is
very much appreciated so how do we go
from knowing you know what entity we're
hovering over which is
fine how do we go from that to actually
being able to click to select something
well um it's pretty simple i'm assuming
that everyone i'm pretty sure
i actually uh i'm pretty sure i
actually um i don't know it's been like
it's been two weeks since i recorded the
last episode but it's been a week for
you guys i guess so it
hasn't been quite so bad but um uh last
last episode i
did uh task you guys with some homework
i think to work out how to do this
now i want to set up i want to make this
series a little bit more interactive
going forward so what i might do is
actually set up some
kind of pull request system or whatever
for you guys to actually submit these
homework assignments and it
might be a good way for you if you're
learning to actually uh have some actual
kind of tasks and exercises that you can
do and and then i might go over some of
them see what the solutions are and
maybe even just integrate some of that
code or at least talk about it as i
implemented myself so that
i can also explain it at the same time
so i might do stuff like that in the
future drop a comment below
if you're interested in something like
that but um again this is
quite trivial all we really have to do
is design a first of all design some
kind of api that lets us select an
entity programmatically i don't think we
have that at the moment
what i mean by that is the only way to
currently select entities is to click on
them
in the scene hierarchy and of course we
get the relevant um
the relevant properties uh pop up as
well as if we have gizmos um
currently enabled you can actually see
the gizmo pop up
so that's the only way to select objects
at the moment we can't programmatically
be like hey select
this entity so we need something like
that that's step one
step two is to simply well the simplest
case would be
when the left mouse button is clicked if
we're within the viewport
um look at what the hover density is and
just
set that entity to be the selected
entity
it's pretty simple right there are a few
things that we have to avoid
um mostly with like uh you know the
gizmos for example if we're hovering
over a gizmo or
using a gizmo the left mouse button is
in fact pressed
but we don't want to suddenly select
this top panel for example
because you can see hover density says
top right
but we're obviously in the middle of an
operation and we don't want to deal with
that
so you need to kind of be aware i guess
of stuff like that so
let's close it and let's make this
happen so scene hierarchy panel
is the thing that is currently kind of
controlling our selection
because you can see we have a selection
context here right we have a get
selected entity but we don't have a
set selected entity so let's uh quickly
write that in so set selected entity
entity entity
and that has to do a few things so first
of all we obviously need to update our
selection context to whatever the entity
is
um but i just want to make sure that um
uh is that actually it i think that i
think that might be it
um let's try with that i don't know
hazel dev has a few more things but then
again this is not hazel dev
um so there is yeah hover into okay
so technically speaking what we should
be able to do now right is
basically go to the events right that we
have here so event
um and then in event we have this on key
press let's do an
on mouse button pressed on mouse button
pressed
which will of course be useful um
for a lot of things inside the editor so
mouse button pressed event
on mouse button pressed um
and then what we're going to do here
is basically check to see if the uh
button
is um
mouse is a mouse code mouse button
mouse i guess is this one i don't know i
didn't write this code someone reflected
it mouse i don't know if mouse is the
best
thing maybe it should be mouse button
because these are all clearly buttons
but
we'll talk about that later so if if get
mouse button is button left
then again all we really need to do is
set the selected entity
um to be whatever the hobbit one is even
if it's
null right now this is a problem because
again this
means that when we're not really
clicking
this could be a click anywhere on the
entire layer and remember the layer
contains the whole
i'm going panel situation so we need to
only make sure that we do that if we're
over the viewport
now i believe we have something called
viewport hovered
so if we're hovering over the viewport
and we click um
you might want to mandate it being um
uh focused or not i'm not sure about
that
um because that way you'd have to click
twice potentially but that might be good
because if you're trying to just
click back on the viewport to activate
it and you don't want to deselect
something
different tools do this differently i
probably won't get into that right now
um basically we'll just say if uh
the viewport is hovered let's go ahead
and do that
right let's give that a go
and yes this was a mistake thank you
stream chat for pointing that out
i don't know how that happened ah
because key press i think was already a
thing
that would explain the compile error
stream's got my back
why not um yeah i think we just have to
return
i always forget i always forget this is
a
um or maybe not i didn't make it a
balloon
so what's wrong with this should be good
now no okay
can't compile any code today um that
apparently is legal
yeah spot impressed event
forgetting all of our types and
hopefully now we should be good to go
should really get it to load big cube in
automatically
but um now if i click uh you should be
seeing here that it's actually selecting
it
right including nothing so if i do this
with gizmos it's much more satisfying
right you can see that now if i click on
something uh it actually selects that
object which is pretty cool
so i can move this around move this
around
move that around oops oh okay so this is
exactly what i was talking about
not only does it well will it select
objects that we don't want like
that well it won't because i guess it's
not a pressed event
but the problem is that you can see when
i click on this
it picks this other object because it's
in front even though the gizmo is in
front
like this will work but if the gizmo is
in front it's gonna select the other
objects or
or um what we saw earlier i can't move
it
what we saw earlier was i think it was
kind of like that and so when we click
over here obviously
in terms of the frame buffer the mouse
pointer is actually over nothing
so when i click it deselects it so
there's a few little issues here that we
need to iron out this stuff is very
minor of course
um and i'm sure all of you guys are
capable of
um fixing it yourselves which you can
definitely uh have a go at doing but
basically um
what am i gonna do so i am gizmo
so there is a little i'm gizmo is using
situation
right so we kind of check this every
frame um i this is a clearly a global
thing and it just returns if the context
is being used
so we could actually just copy this
exact code we don't have to like store
our own boolean or anything like that if
we don't want to
unless we want the state to persist
which i'm not sure about that
um i just literally don't know but um
let's try and do something like uh if
it's not
using um but also i believe if it's not
covered because
using is fine that's if we're in the
middle of a use i don't actually think
we need that one to be honest
i don't think harvard is the same as
using
so there's just a few little caveats
here i guess that we need to
iron out so um that's fine
uh and then you can see it still does
the selection because what we're
actually after is harvard
and i believe that um
using bounds no well using bounds of the
is the wrong thing
is over it's probably what we want so
make sure that we're not actually
hovering over that i am
guizmo thing
all right so um now
if i'm behind this and i click you can
see we don't lose focus and same with
being like that if i click
you can see we're still good to go now
one thing that does happen is if i hit
alt
which obviously activates the camera and
then i click i lose my selection
so yet another little case um we could
be like cameron used or something like
that but for now i'm just going to do
input is key pressed key code
or key left alt
so if that's not pressed so this is
becoming pretty long
um the way that i would probably
uh fix this or make it a little bit
better
is by just essentially writing a
function that dictates whether or not
we're actually in the viewport or if
something's
supposed to be blocking an event
directly into the viewport
so um that's probably what i would do
because for example
can you could write a function that
returns a boolean called
can pick or can mouse pick and it would
just return this and that's a little bit
easier to manage than this huge
like if statement because obviously like
you know we know that this is mouse
picking
but this code doesn't actually have
anything to do with mouse like
it doesn't say the word mouse pick
anywhere so it makes sense to us at the
moment
but as code grows it's it's very nice to
be able to
if needed you know bring it out into a
function or at least add a comment or
something like that
but then if you can simplify you know
expressions like this
to make them uh bullying statements that
return things
um you know like functions i mean then i
would i usually
tend to do that just because again when
you read through the code
don't worry about performance and
everything like that i'm sure it'll be
fine probably be inlined anyway
um but even if it did have a little tiny
performance penalty i'd probably still
do it
because it's just nice to be able to
read code that looks good and
that will probably be better than um
being like oh yeah yeah the reason my
engine is slow is because i write little
boolean statements that are actually
functions and then
that causes a jump in my code okay
so um uh yeah so now i can hit alt
and obviously do anything i want with
the left mouse button and it doesn't
select things
so the next step is kind of just to use
this a little bit um
uh control obviously something i can do
to snap stuff as well
you know we didn't test the other gizmos
but i'm sure they're going to be fine
i can pick this uh and move this
around and um you can see that
uh it's all in screen space by the way
so that might be a problem because if we
go really small
you can see this gizmo is basically
unusable i don't realistically think
anyone will be using
uh the editor in that small of a
resolution
but with something like this you can see
um it works perfectly fine
and the intended use is kind of at least
probably at a 1080p
resolution because i don't think that um
i don't think you should probably ever
have this window not maximized
so that's another thing we can probably
do is start up maximized
anyway this was a pretty short episode
which is nice i like having short and
sweet episodes
um but we're now at the point where
obviously we can actually well
reasonably well we don't have a grid or
anything this is very quickly
evolving into a 3d engine actually i
could imagine having a grid there
learning three models positioning stuff
around
um that would probably be very fun but i
don't think we're gonna get there i
don't think
we're gonna go there just yet because i
did promise like a 2d workflow and i
think we probably should do that
so um i'm not even sure what we'll touch
on next i'll have a good thing and
probably discussion with the stream
uh don't forget that i do stream on
twitch or tv slash the channel pretty
often
well this is the third time this week
actually so um
[Music]
uh so uh yeah so we will see but thank
you guys for watching hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button below and
also you can go to patreon.com to help
support
this engine and everything i'm doing
here on youtube and all the tutorial
videos that i make uh you'll also get
access to
hazel dev that um
a lot of stuff i need to make a video
about hazel there that i can just refer
people to it too i think but
actually you can watch the latest devlog
if you want to see the kind of stuff
that's inside
hazeldev that you could get your paws on
if you uh
if you help support on um patreon thank
you guys for watching i'll see you next
time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you